[Music]
do we
all know who lily pons is i don't know
what that is she's big really big yeah
she has
41.2 million followers is she mexican
no
you're right so if you guys don't know
who lily pons is like me
here we go here's a nice half naked
picture of her that's a great picture
yes
what does she do she does the she i
think she came from the vine crowd
yeah yeah she she was the first person
to hit like a million or a billion loops
on vine or whatever she has like um
an album out yeah yeah she's just like
uh
like overall content creator yeah across
she's an overall entertainer
a genius she's killing it though yeah
she's only 24.
whoa that's how young she was i thought
that's at 22.
22. no it's 24. yeah she cause she just
had her birthday
wow and this is killing it this video is
about her birthday
oh oh no is she in trouble no no no no
she's
she's just posting her birthday stuff
here but
one other person also posted something
about her birthday
and that was her plastic surgeon and
this she always says she has plastic
surgery oh for sure okay but no one's
ever really seen
the before yeah she posted all the time
her
face looks her nose was crazy really
yeah what did she post or not
to post this on your birthday on
someone's birthday that's rude yeah and
this
wasn't her posting okay fine maybe she
has posted it before
but it wasn't her post he's like
promoting how
like look at the magic i got like
look at the guys i'm a [ __ ] badass
aren't i
like he's it's making it about him and
he said happy birthday
that's rude i should have just put a
picture of the after
and just like my good friend or my
client and it could be assumed that like
just by saying client happy birthday to
lily pons who's been here before he
could have just done that
well he's doing that for self-promotion
like this guy
lele has like millions of [ __ ]
followers he's like i need business
but uh on on a birthday it's like a
roast
yeah it feels like you're roasting the
[ __ ] so i i saw it right when it
happened and i was like
god damn that's [ __ ] up but then i saw
her comment underneath being like all
like super happy and then i saw
her repost that picture in her story so
i was like huh
yeah maybe she doesn't care maybe yes or
maybe it's just she's getting paid out
maybe because she does post those type
of pictures she does all the time
but so i feel like even though it's like
hey i know it's your birthday but
remember how [ __ ] up you looked well
that's assuming she's insecure about
that
yeah and that's assuming that the doctor
even thinks that way
yeah doctor might just be like a face is
a face and i just shape it
yeah and look at what i did this is the
before this is the after i got talent
yeah true well i mean maybe he doesn't
think that way but then i think for the
rest of the world how we think
that's everyone was like dude you're
[ __ ] up yeah that's how twitter
responds
that's how i would respond i think
that's not normal most of people think
about plastic surgery is we think that
it's immoral
we think it's deceiving we think it's
weird so that's why
we think that most people would be
ashamed if you get plastic surgery
not me though yeah like don't i don't
mind about like whatever you want
because i'm
getting my stuff worked on so it's like
i don't think it in that case it matters
but also i'm like
that's [ __ ] up on her birthday but she
replied right you said she was happy and
then she said oh you think she was
politics like she's like [ __ ]
but i gotta like go in and go
oh it could have been that where she's
like oh like because people are like
either harassing him or like making fun
of her so let me like mediate both but
that's such a funny picture that he used
on the left
yeah it's just i think it's just a funny
post
from a plastic surgeon because it feels
like a roast but he's not a comedian
he's a medical professional
yeah so it's just like the the what's
coming out from a medical professional
is just this is funny it makes sense
because like when you go to the plastic
surgeons don't they have like a binder
like a book and then you kind of get to
see
before we have a photo the whole
instagram is that now oh yeah that's all
they're not just going to post
themselves they're posting with their
work so people can go and think but it's
like
but they ask for consent too because
even like a contractor if a contractor
like on my birthday
post the before and after of my house or
something i'm like
even though that doesn't hurt me or
anything it just feels weird i'm like
wait what
or you could just wish me happy birthday
like a normal human being
like it's just weird that like i worked
on that i don't know because they're
making it about them
yeah yeah yeah look at what i did for
you i mean on that note though it is a
great advertisement
i have to say like damn like oh if i
ever want any work done
it looks like adam sandberg on the left
[ __ ] adam sandberg
yeah snl snl andy and
a little more before and after adam
sandler okay this one before was it it
wasn't as wild
well it's just the lighting made it
worse there's also many when the
lighting was intense
true i know there's a big difference
like you don't there's also a
professional photo
with makeup what else does she do just
her nose from what i know
she looks like lips but we never know
and also yeah you don't know
but she's also so young in those other
photos
yeah it should look like just like one's
like 15 and one's like 20. so like the
ones that was
before which was braces thrown into that
nose though
no the nose obviously that's oh that's
the dude that's him
i mean i guess oh [ __ ] because if it was
like
i would have just posted that picture of
us together right wait what's wrong with
her nose
on the left she just has like a this one
or this one can't even tell what's
this what's what's not i mean i don't
think there's anything wrong with either
it goes down like this she just maybe
didn't like her profile
or she could have had breathing issues
we don't know that's true
i mean there's a lot of influencers that
after plastic surgery it went really
well for them
really really well like a lot so
it's a business move okay
speaking from experience no no not me i
should i should show it off more
yeah the thumbnail views get more clicks
oh yeah
you do a bikini haul and i guess so it
does it does thanks guys
yeah i'll keep doing that one i think
for me i'm like i'll talk anything i get
i'll talk about
like i'll just say i'm not like it's not
an issue
because i feel like there's more people
that are like oh thank you for talking
about it because i was thinking about it
but i've been kind of like afraid to i
think that's why people like her so much
because she's so open about it like look
how blessed
she's real yeah you want real people you
don't want fake ass
but it's like what was his intent of
posting that maybe he's just like
business look how real i am with my
hands
i would have more so just taking a
picture like the one that he has with
her yeah post that happy birthday it's
very nice
um if i saw that i'd be like holy [ __ ]
he went to her obviously
if he has a picture with her he didn't
just see her on the street and take a
photo with her and but i'm a big fan
cause that's almost like if kanye had
like a manager
and he's like before like look what i
found him this guy's so broke he has
holes in his hands
and then he's like look at him he's a
[ __ ] billionaire now it's like
or you could just say happy birthday
normally
that's true yeah he was definitely using
the opportunity
or a better example be like you know
scooter braun is justin bieber's uh
manager
the it's like the picture of justin
bieber being a street performer with a
couple dollars in a guitar case yeah and
then him being balling as [ __ ] now it's
like wait what or you could just say
happy birthday yeah
is he also american the guy uh he's in
new york
yeah oh his name doesn't sound american
so i don't have no idea because in like
other countries we perceive things as
rude when other countries don't
so for them it might be completely fine
and it's not even saying that they're
just dumb and true we're being assisted
before
we're like we're like that's so rude
yeah yeah for them it could be
completely fine and then we're just
taking it
wrong we're being sensitive because she
used to be busted
we're just like wow how can you put that
shitty picture up there
that's so [ __ ] up that's [ __ ] up on
our part oh
that's true like you know like an asian
family like for the first time
like my mom can't wait to show you
pictures of me when i'm like look at my
son's dick when he's five
i mean i'm just like in the bathtub and
you're like wait what like your mom did
that no yeah just brings all these weird
pictures that like not to show me his
dick
it's a picture of justin's dick his mom
i'm like
she might have done that no she's very
innocent but she brings out like
not the most flattering pictures you
know i mean like she brings out like she
has mom eyes so
every picture of you is charming for her
but a lot i know a lot of parents are
like that where they bring out like
pictures that are like
why the [ __ ] you can keep these around
for
true if you guys could do plastic
surgery
let's just say let's keep it to the face
what would you guys change about
yourselves do you ever think about that
i would do my ears my ears stick out
loud
cheeks for sure not that i ever do it
though cheeks yeah cause like even when
i lost weight my cheeks stayed
almost the exact same size so that
obviously i don't have to lose a lot
more weight but then the cheeks and then
one of my friends she's got cheek
reduction yeah she has abs
and she still has like big cheeks oh
she's just i have big cheeks yeah
but it's like for me i feel like it's i
would rather have them up here but not
like down here
also friends are like just skin and then
it makes their jaws look all chiseled
and stuff and i'm like damn that's right
if someone told me that if i changed
like a few things
and it could make me a billionaire i'd
do it oh [ __ ] yeah me too
i think you would even get titties if it
made you a billionaire
i would i
the thing is like i for me i would never
i wouldn't do it for vanity
reasons like there's no reason for me i
don't think
she she got the way i'm not even talking
about her i'm talking about me
what do you mean that changing it would
make you a billionaire though just
because you look better people in her
case opportunity
in her case though if she looked the way
that she did it's much much harder for
her to
grab attention i think she got the
attention when she looked like that
though
that's what i'm saying did she look she
floated before she blew up before she
blew it before
i didn't know what she looked like for
me i thought she looked fine but i think
when you
then when you see what they do after
they're like oh she does look better
and then you put the comparison but i
think she was funny and that's why she
blew up especially the vine comedy she
was like killing it at
yeah you don't get 40 something well i
guess you do never mind i'll take it
back
i don't i don't remember her pre the way
that she looked
because i just remember her like the hot
lily
yeah no she got work done and then uh
she did take advantage of it because
then she also came out with that book
was like
uh basically like my globe store like of
course her looks isn't
everything yeah but i'm saying that i
know that
especially for women right like their
looks play a heavy role
on their ability to grab attention so
like
that's something we can't deny and i
don't know if it's the same for men
like for example like uh if there is a
hot girl it's highly likely that girls
and guys
will take that second to look at you
more and
and click that video or look at that uh
for guys it's almost the opposite you
have guys that are huge in hollywood and
stuff but they have that kind of like
they're not well i think it's because
they make up for it though
well they're just unique looking they
just look weird but where it's for the
opposite
depends on what industry you're in yeah
because like
if you're a car salesman like i don't
know do you have to look good maybe you
have to look presentable
but do you have to be sexy i don't know
maybe it'll help in sales
but what about a night like if you're if
you work in a cubicle you don't really
work with people
does it matter yeah like i don't know
for social media and stuff i think she
did
like i think if she stayed the same
honestly for like the fashion or runway
that type of modeling or whatever she
would have probably been like
too clean or too perfect because they
like the imperfections in that
in that realm too that's true i think
also like the
to give her credit and also just other
talent like her like or even dudes or
whatever
um i think get being able to grab
people's attention
um is really good because it helps out
with you know just more eyeballs
but i think what you do with that
attention is
like kind of the genius part right
because yes substance that's what's
how many hot girls are there oh [ __ ] and
they get all the attention in the world
but they couldn't turn that to a billion
dollars
whereas she probably can because she has
the know-how she's able to
take the attention and then knows what
to do with that attention right
i agree genius right yeah i think she's
really smart time to get implants guys
i'll go bigger let's go all of us she's
posing with an alligator but she's like
a kid she's a kid here yeah for sure
old photos she has an alligator pet a
nose makes a huge difference y'all you
don't understand
yeah ariana grande is another example of
that she used to have kind of a similar
nose too and she had worked out biggest
difference between the before and after
is her smile
and the makeup too she smiles a lot more
with her mouth but less with her eyes
it's so it's like now it's evened out
it's such a big difference when you're
also
like 12. yeah yeah yeah yeah where you
don't know how to smile it's
that yearbook yeah i think that it's
funny thing when you look at kids
smiling they only smile with their mouth
yeah they don't know something i'm tired
of this picture
they're smiling for mom hurry up
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
you